yeah so he's all kinds of messed up and
I'll make this guy get a change from
going all right you're giving up all
that all the years the way I've been the
whole change just right now yeah love
does that woman lifestyle that is
clearly not letting me leave very easily
and keeps getting in the way of my life
even still what's going on reject nation
Greg Alba here John Humphrey over here
okay so we're gonna do a reaction to
Fifty Shades freed the one-minute teaser
trailer that they released before we do
that I wanted to give my thoughts on
fifty shades darker it is exactly 2:18
a.m. in the morning right now you know
this trailer dropped people a lot of
people are asking us to check it out but
we haven't seen fifty shades darker why
would we do a reaction you know you give
commentary on that we gotta see fifty
shades darker to understand the context
I feel like we made it a semi big deal
when the first trailer came out for
fifty shades darker but like the second
the taste dissolved we were like yeah
cuz like the first one I went out to see
that in the theaters on opening night
just to see what that would be like I
was a great help to do that no time you
know okay I want to get my quick
thoughts on fifty shades darker I think
that this one is way better than fifty
shades of gray I feel like the first
half hour I really felt like the
director understood what the hell this
movie is is you know it's a soap opera
it's it's like a rated R so prop so it's
a woman's romantic novel oh you know
it's the big hall softcore I don't want
your like a whole review of fifty shades
darker we're gonna just say like I
actually kind of enjoyed the movie well
there's like a lot of people said it was
boring and I'm like that's not what I
felt when I was watching this movie too
long but like it is having it yeah every
everything is a lot more on pitch to
where it's enjoyable for what it is I
think it's the kind of movie as a guy
that you can enjoy if you're at home
it's a wacky movie
it's full of moments where you're like
why haven't you sought help yeah when
it's heart isn't a better is in the
right place I guess when it's covering
the beats that you care about for this
country yeah one thing I thought about
fifty shades darker was like I thought
that I forget they're Dakota Johnson and
Jamie Porter Dakota Johnson Jamie Dornan
their performances in it when they're
like talking sexy to each other like
that scene when when she when he puts
the ball stuff up her you know you know
I'm freaking you do you know when they
do the extreme underwear I was like
that's one of the sexiest scenes of this
is sexiest it's aware that's exactly
it's aware and the and the soundtrack is
just somebody is sex playlist so yeah in
a weird way you start to see the
potential watching you're like okay like
if this is actually kind of a weird
exploration if this was like American
Psycho or something yeah I feel like
this could have been is Helen Roddick
dark thriller that could feel borderline
horror movie about because I like the
concept
yeah but invested as much in in like the
psychology of the care of this is Agnes
sex yeah it can be fascinating
Oobi to do the psychology of this sex
yeah that's what I think it'll be
fascinating more likely to get an nc-17
rating seeing the emotional context
behind the sexuality because I like this
concept this dude who's you know like is
it's more than just he's he's crazy in
the bedroom it's his lifestyle it's the
way he taught you at all occasions it's
like penis submissive he's so dominant
in this movie really seems like it just
gives you every guy's fantasy that the
[ __ ] up guy will one day change with
no therapeutic help whatsoever and the
whole movies instead of going goes right
for these people whole movies him just
going that's not me anymore and he just
proves that is an emotional sexual
super8 you know I really
movie no struggle sex demons also
dispensing righteous you know sort of
BDSM ish sex this would be so
interesting if it was like about these
two people that do love each other and
want to be together but it's the the
things that happen in terms of sex that
really tear them apart and it could be
an interesting conversation I wanted to
see a very Christian Grey is it's the
whole time it's easy he's about to break
bad he's about sex scenes intensity of
public Basic Instinct or something you
know the thing is like watching this
movie we sat there going like there's so
many other movies this movie could be
like a sex version like your options are
so long this could be the new Basic
Instinct yeah you could almost make it
like a horror movie like a sex American
Psycho I totally like a maniac style
like sex slasher oh yeah the thing is
the film's terrible yes it's not a good
film but I find it really enjoy but it
sounds really cheesy and quality exactly
I feel like to just do what it doesn't
do it right I feel like the first one
was like we need to try to be a good
movie yeah one thing I hate though is
like there's a lot of they're about to
have sex they don't have sex well let's
make sure we could get a shot at Dakota
Johnson's tits for just one second we
get it's a random insert of jimmy dore
naked right here yeah okay cool yeah
because we cancer the sex thing is the
nc-17 right so you're just gonna shot in
them naked so we try to please don't
from the fans a little bit because so
much potential to be like a movie that
has messages in a movie that could get a
point across but it doesn't ever go
there what I gotta say though is when
they're having sex and like they're
dirty talking cuz I feel like all of
Jaime dorans character note he has for
himself is like he's like I can narrow
down my character to one thing he is
always one to have sex that's why when
he's talking sexy gonna always something
yeah
that's why anytime he's talking sexy
he's [ __ ] great he's great at talking
sexy and then when they're talking sexy
to each other and she's like I really
believe them I think these two actors
must have slept together at least one
time you got oh my gosh you're so
comfortable
with each other in those let's see the
last one it's like those sex scenes
weren't even sexy here I thought they
loved them over most or and the music
choices for all them are so like crazy
and it's the sex is choreographed to the
music it's edited to the music it's it's
it knows what it is so we just watch
this not be curious to see if I remember
any of it or not because the thing about
the first movie is like I remember being
kind of like that was more sex maybe
than I've seen yeah sure but it didn't
leave an impression I mean I don't
remember anything about that movie
watching this one I was like yeah they
bothered to make this at least like
Michael Bay shiny about it yeah like
super duper sexy and you're like yeah I
hated the way it ended though I hated
the way it ended yeah because it doesn't
have a real movie it has a oh now I see
why Fifty Shades freed is coming out so
close to fifty shades darker oh yeah
everything's great the end I think
there's the last half hour I think where
Connor was this movie needs more a
conflict whole movies about them getting
along like random helicopter situation
to make her yeah marry this could be a
chance to do something good and like use
a big to package it and I just don't
think they're quite patreon shout out
the we're gonna do format beer Matt Matt
so for the end of the video will give
your patient the day shout out well John
are you ready to watch the Fifty Shades
freed trailer
we vow to love you faithfully respect
you
to keep you safe first of all as a
postulant
[Laughter]
she's still surprised by stuffy
[Music]
jaws woo what okay I see where this
movie's going trailer drops this no fan
for that was that that is the trailer
hey guys uh trailer that's a tease
that's a that's a definitive teaser
trailer a teaser for show they get
married creepy stalker guy from last
movie comes in and breaks he's a picker
and there's gunshot I hate that trailer
I hate it because it's fifty shades
darker did they show like these gunshot
did you even see the gunshots in the
fifty shades darker nebula gunshots I'm
like fifty shades darker and then
there's nothing in that movie and I what
I don't like what these movies do I
think they played up the helicopter
crash in that trailer they did yeah this
movie works best when it's just about
them having sex and like arguing back
and forth about what their relationship
is and why yeah how their past effects
are now in future it's all this like
other thriller stuff and I'm like I
don't really need any of this you know
it's trying to make it more exciting
than what it is your priorities right
now though were you four you said that
during the yeah sometimes it feels like
it's for like a teenage 13 year old
audience and other times it feels like a
woman in their 20s and then other times
it's like a forty year old woman who's
married you know it's trying to cover
all ages of any female demographic if I
can get into sex well am like caters
certain things to the dudes who will
inevitably end up watching yeah it's
yeah it just seems like every scene is a
little bit different on every level so
that everybody gets something yeah
here's a retro moment for the older
people and like all that stuff with a
gunshot so I'm like that I'm sure that's
not gonna be most of the movie that's
not what your movies gonna be and
there's like the last one they the fifty
shades darker marking charming isn't
it's exciting thriller from like Kim
Basinger shows up for like three
and then Marcia Gay Harden shows up for
like three scenes I don't know if it's
just like them setting up what happens
if fifty shades free to finish a story
supposed to be like it's always like you
said jaws when we were watching the
second movie I was reminded of Halloween
half the time yeah like if this is just
like this yes Michael Myers and this one
makes it look it's sex Joss I feel like
there's so much more potential to focus
on him repressing this side of him and
she wants him to change but he can't he
loves her so he's trying to change but
it's tearing him apart like that would
just be so it's like on an extreme level
of like a rich guy who's a who's a who's
a sadist that would be a fascinating
movie to me like a psychological yeah
he's like Patrick Bateman he's gonna
crack one day and then they got all this
other stuff about passes dong a woman
who is like any yeah exactly
this is him getting along and then like
other people from his past and then the
jealous dude over here I'm like what is
what is all this stuff is what he wants
to kill us
everybody wants to laugh good thing with
this movie is it really hinges like the
way they make these movies is it really
hinges on the fact that they think their
audience really wants these two to make
[ __ ] work yeah I want this religion yes
but there's always something like in
fifty shades darker at one point he's
being mr. Dom to that one woman who
pulled the gun on them and then he's the
old man he just switches he switches
into rageful Dom and he tells her for
once will you just do as you're told and
has his assistant escort her out dude
hes tealing those dude he was mean he
was so abusive in that moment and then
three hours later after they were you
know Ana shows up okay I guess you
changed because you said it yeah I guess
that's what they set out to say at the
beginning of the movie they're like no
rules with this that's our rule is no
rule we're gonna just do this that makes
the lines all grey well you're like hold
on there yeah right now when he swears
he doesn't mean
but the movie really ends on a note of
oh he's just changed he changed from the
beginning and he didn't go back at all
yeah you know he went back for his would
second but that had no concern for Ana
that took place even though that was
really she almost got killed
maybe just one long setup for Fifty
Shades free I really just don't want the
I don't know what I want from that I
don't know cuz it looks just like a sex
thriller like it's trying to be it it's
yeah everyone's trying to kill each
other now it feels like it feels like it
feels like a soap opera and at times I
like it at times I like it honestly I do
and Jamie Dornan you know I like this
portrayal of him he's not just rich DOM
douchebag he's like yeah she's so cocky
you can't reminds me of Danny Randy he's
still cocky but he's also just trying to
be a normal dude and he and I like his
relationship banter he has with her you
know I believe them in those moments
when the system when they're connected
in those moments I believe it when
they're having a good time they're
talking dirty their phone around all
those moments I really do believe it
it's weird it's like this movie is all
this is one of the rare movies it's
better when the stakes are lower because
all this other stuff is just distracting
from the interesting stuff explore it I
don't care about the weird gritty
thriller happening in the but also next
dom is also jealous once because fifty
shades darker really marketed that and
yeah market that I'm like I won't be
fooled again now it spoiled yeah oh you
thought it ended on a good note for
these two uh what just destroy their
happily I'm not that really wants these
guys to work out I just keep going to
ask you know what stuff this guy watched
his mom died of a drug overdose and now
he's all kinds of messed up after being
sexually abused by Kim Basinger the
actress not the character yeah that's
actually because I basically watched her
almost die no I'm not the mom overdosed
oh shoot would you not paying attention
I thought my David was his mom yeah she
adopted him oh yeah
got ya wow you would fail the Schmidt I
was making yeah so he's all kinds of
messed up and I'm like this guy get a
change from going all right we're giving
up all that all the years the way I've
been all changed just love does that
woman that is clearly not letting me
leave very easily and keeps getting in
the way of my life even still clearly
needs therapeutic treatment well so Anna
needs therapy because she needs to
figure out why she's so drawn to this
guy you know yes she was like
emotionally repressed and clearly needs
help and gets like Rachel with it and
then she attracts other stalker dude who
works who she works under and this woman
has a pattern of attracting men with
violent sexual tendencies towards her
she needs to give therapeutic you know
to find out what's up with that his past
of why she is the way she is there's so
much potential thing is you never get
enough of Anna's life on her own to know
who she is yeah really you see what
happens at her work which is good you
know you see one facet and what she does
with Christian and the rest of the time
like I don't know anything about you
yeah kid it could be anything
like that's that's weird I feel like you
could do a whole other movie which they
probably will do it so yeah they do or
they rewrite it from Edwards point of
viewers something or it's like here's
everything that happened just in the
pray I have said to myself I said I
think I said to you at one point when we
were watching the movie like Christian
Grey would be way more interesting if he
was looking out but I got criminal in
some way like for sexual stuff yeah he
was some kind of like why yeah yeah it's
like now he's just a rich Jew with a sex
fetish you just goes hard and everything
he's into doing nebulous business deals
and this is the point of why we talk so
long about this is because we see word
it could all go and I feel like when
people watch like 50 shades darker
especially after like hearing all those
reviews way back when people probably
talk about boredom and all these things
I really hear someone mentioned like
here's where the potential it has to go
it would be well there would be a dream
projects appreciate if they're gonna
spend money to do it anyway
as well be as good as it could possibly
be I think like Oh a lot of book
adaptations especially for books like
this is writers get very afraid to
change the mists source material god
dude God no justice to your audience man
one of my favorite segments on Cinna fix
is they do like what's the difference
between books and the movie like the
Croat or Jurassic Park and you see the
differences you're like wow the writers
really changed a lot of the book but
because it makes the movie better and
what they're going for well it makes it
fit more movies yeah you know cuz the
format is totally different and it's it
probably but I can feel it would just
feel it with this movie like it's very
obvious you were like let's take this
scene trim out this dialogue here it's
that's all I was doing the whole time
yeah yeah and I feel like if they had
the room to check be bold and change it
man Kubrick this is like a horror
thriller like a sexual erotic thriller
like a good Michael Douglas Basic
Instinct fatal attraction except we're
in a feminist stage now so we got to
make the woman the protagonist who's in
danger you know yeah in some ways like a
weird ultimate fantasy that just has a
violent sub just won't stop you know for
some reason Anna and and Christian both
you guys I really hope you guys get
therapy because if you guys are gonna
need couples counseling okay this is a
very temporary you guys are rushing this
is can make it work this is a movie
that's depending on moon going I have to
root for this unhealthy couple to get
together it's not about watching a
cat-and-mouse game between the two yeah
it's about them just we're moving in now
we're getting married we're not flirting
with our boundaries and like yeah yeah
now it's like we're committing to each
other quality time yeah it's all okay
all right so Matt beer
Matt beer the reason we wanted to give
you a shout out for fifty Shades freed
fifty shades because every single time I
was watching christiane and Dakota
Johnson I kept imagining that it was not
Jamie Dornan it was you Matt beer it was
you I think that would be so much hotter
if you were the new Christian Grey
I've seen your face on Google hangout
hangouts and I know you're like what
you're like five five or so and I just
think that's so much sexier
we measured that so I would love it if
you could audition to be at least in
like a stage adaptation of Fifty Shades
of Grey I don't think you'd be the
perfect choice I really what I hope for
this channel is that one day in our
merch store either I guess on unspread
shirt designed by humans would be to
have special glasses that have Matt
beers face and when you watch this movie
it'll sink in real 3d we love you Matt
beer keep drinking it's the best thing
you can do for you anyway guys we get
the fifty shades free trailer excited
for the fifty shades free trail are you
into this are you are you stealing this
teaser for the trailer I mean you
titillated you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can click that notification
bell dad John home Twitter and Instagram
social media manager of the real rejects
patreon.com real rejects become a patron
to check today take care of people buy a
shirt if you want to sure